hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to soma I just want to
give an update on the main screen here
the eyes are starting to crack around
the edges a little bit the face is
obviously pulling farther apart the red
light might be a bit brighter than it
was before
and I have noticed that the face looks
like it's just projected on multiple
layers of machinery going back and back
into the darkness
so that's cheerful anyway back to the
game alright before we get to back into
it I just wanted to say something that
kind of profoundly affected me after my
last choice in the last episode I
haven't had a game that after I was done
playing it I debated in my head for
hours if I made the right choice I
haven't done that in the game I can't
recall a game where that's happened
before but what's interesting about this
is that I don't even know if it's an
until dawn situation where my choices
here affect the outcome of the game I
really don't know and the best thing
that I can do is kind of trust my heart
and trust my first instincts on what to
do in these situations because I've got
no idea what's right I literally have no
clue if I'm doing anything right so I
will go forward I can figure this out
can i I have no idea if I can I'm not
terribly smart mind you I already did
the dangle duty oh oh oh there you go
okay I got it
alright cool then I did it now can I
throw the switch
no how about now wait oh there we go I
didn't push it in all the way close I
supposed to know all right there we go
then I figured now I solved your PO okay
I'm assuming that was supposed to look
like a faith a face and mouth opening up
to some subtle imagery about I'm about
to be eaten whole I mean we're all very
impressed by your giant door hey can I
go in now I just want to get on good
terms with bubble but again that's
literally my only desire right now I
just want to be good hello I'm a good
person right
I do good things I make good choices
baby
okay achievement unlocked the dumb cat
okay oh it's just a big version of the
other things I was walking into so what
I'm assuming is that this is theta right
here this is beta and this is supposed
to get me to where I need to go
as far as getting to the arc and in the
arc maybe I'll be able to load up my
consciousness into it and then be able
to live forever in a dream world
hello and we're back
left-right up-down everything seems to
me we're okay
well this is all very impressive but
there doesn't seem to know anyone there
I was about to ask the same question
that didn't seem to be anybody here well
Katherine we found food yep sure did
Katherine can't hear me right now
because she's in a box Oh
there seem to be weird growths in here
too I really did wonder what this is all
about because the enemy that I found
earlier was also covered in that in the
handled region but he seemed to be
giving off a lot of electromagnetism is
that blood that might very well be blood
all right then
anybody in there any other robot humans
robot with humans hello anybody oh this
no yes no maybe I should have just
followed the blood because the blood was
the most obvious thing anyway so yeah of
course I was supposed to follow the
blood [ __ ]
boobity boobity boobity boobity boo oh
no oh no I need a better chip do I have
to kill another robot I sure hope not
okay so I got to do something to find
another chip somewhere around here or
else I'm never gonna be able to go where
I need to go so oh I see okay I get it I
know what I need to do I need to break
something I need to not use my brain I
need to use my brawn I need to use my
LeBron James
Kobe crap hey on another basketball but
Larry Bird I did it I made a sports
reference thing I know sports baseball
oh here we are both Kathryn help right
here yep we're here yep okay great
can I check ourselves a submarine there
will be nothing stopping us when we have
done that really I sure have a lot of
machines and vehicles down here what
makes this one so special it's the only
transport they can go into the abyss
without cracking like a can of soup
Kansas soup don't crank how did they get
the art down the abyss in the first
place that's a good question I suppose
they did it the hard way just walked
didn't realize that was an option
cat what's it like inside the ark is it
like a movie or virtual reality no of
course not you know like real life but
so I read better pleasant temperature
air good weather so people in New York
just walk around pretending it's the
real world you don't have to pretend
it's perfectly immersive and it can just
sustain itself yes attached to a probe
you won't buy solar panels they could
survive for thousands of years that's
amazing just thinking about the earth
being what it is and us setting out to
save the final remains of humanity it's
it's heroic at least it feels worth
doing here we go the dumb bat did a damn
it it was too good to be true
of course it's wrong seems to be
infected it's quarantined hold on we
need a security cipher how bad is it
it's we don't write these things down
type of bed maybe someone's still around
it could tell us what it is sure let's
go with that I'll just unlock the other
doors for you so you can explore the
station okay sounds good I'm glad that
this is all happening and I'll be
exploring alone in eulogy procuring a
woman with me he knows the cipher it's
the only way you're fair a bit done back
Oh unless you're gonna stay here with
someone who knows the security sector
wait I thought you're being sarcastic
about that assuming that everyone would
be dead or turned into machines but I
guess if they're a machine I can talk to
him then but I don't know what it is
maybe it's a deep philosophical thing
that I have in my heart but it just
seems kind of sad not heroic because the
last remnants of humanity will go on
drifting into space living a purely
meaningless existence as they wander
around unable to sustain itself and
eventually just dying when the equipment
fails isn't that sad all right wait
anyway I'll leave that up to you guys
because I honestly I'm not qualified to
answer those questions okay so I'm here
the done bat is over yonder away I need
whoa that doesn't make any black box
beacon I'm assuming that means other
people are machines that doesn't your
friends move down
I'm your dad to the gate and the habitat
that's so strange I don't like this at
all
something tells me oh man dad missing
dead dead dead dead missing missing dead
missing missing missing dead okay so
there's some people that aren't dead and
there's a bunch of guests from other
stations is there anyone that seems to
stand out in all this see none of these
names look familiar I don't see mr.
Munchie so he's obviously long gone okay
I guess that's it then I'll be on my way
don't I mean hopefully you can
communicate with we've a little tear
through the intercom system and
hopefully I'll be able to talk better
someday one can only hope
oh that doesn't look good can I go
through here now
boo boo boo I don't have an omni tool
what door did you unlock hi Catherine
what door did you unlock oh I was
supposed to walk her towards these
things how could I not have known that
hello
I'm gonna go in the other one first
because it looks more diabolical that's
probably where I need to be ooh this
looks lovely I'm gonna not mm-hm I'm
gonna go the other way because just in
case this has a temporary thing that I
need immediately no this doesn't look
any better at all I'm completely wrong
about everything
in fact this looks even worse than the
last one I'm pretty sure I'm gonna die
very very soon I'll get it either it's
like they all just cleared out hmm maybe
they were forced out by horrible
monstrosity is created by the cancerous
growths all over the ship it's only a
guess it's dairy per game Gary can I use
this no I'm a machine I'm programmed not
to kill or something I don't know
probably not that's probably a lie well
the book
maybe the shuttle station should we go
check you got a bad feeling about I
almost had a heart attack screw you
hello grubby for good luck my version of
robbing is throwing on the floor oh crap
I hate bathrooms hello hello I mean
while I'm pondering all these
theoretical questions I sometimes forget
that I'm actually playing a horror game
buy made by the company that does horror
games better than pretty much anyone
else
oh hello I thought you were a nice doing
something wrong oh sure he's stuck on
one I'm just worried about the
colleagues uh-huh what about the you
that's walking around that's probably
not to do whoa oh oh no oh no was I
supposed to be checking in the toilet
seats because I didn't kind of want to
do that I don't even know if I'm
supposed to be around here it's probably
all fruitless task just looking in the
toilets what kind of weirdo live at
whenever I walk into a place especially
one with bathrooms I immediately go and
check all the toilets who would hide
something in the toilets you son of a
[ __ ] game
you're not gonna distract me from the
fact that I know that you're terrifying
but I don't want to remember that yeah I
mean we barely gotten into the meat of
the game so I imagine there's going to
be quite a lot why did they seal all the
doors in
I don't like this I don't like this at
all
I don't like this in the least is
absolutely the worst hello who's there
it's not a Final Fantasy 7 poster or is
that the asteroid that came and
destroyed the world that's to put that
on a poster on your wall so you're
always reminded of your impending death
oh that's not good
is that from the movie sunshine all
right what am I looking at here
this is detonator of some sort power
sources batteries electrical diagram
what is going on over there okay I'm
hearing a lot of bangs and clangs and
because this is a new game I don't
necessarily know which one's gonna be a
bad bang or a good bang Oh Catherine
shun Catherine found a room
Hey that's murder hey to bring something
souvenir yeah
just memories what about this
your teddy bear could use some repairs
Toby always breaks he's top-heavy so he
keeps falling over so put a weight on
the bottom I seriously doubt you from
anything useful in there okay you don't
know that I'm gonna look very thoroughly
through all your personal things hello
oh I didn't realize you were from China
I agent I might be wrong there don't
judge me there's no hood type babes on
that in China wait honestly ignore
everything I said
Imogen read tested a machine today is
clearly corrupted by the wahoo but more
importantly it was assembled in a
seemingly primitive way like when
someone has specifically created it for
y ou to steal when activated the Machine
mimicked the room and read along with it
at some point she was scanned and then
loaded as a simulation inside the
digital space the presentation shock
read and was quickly terminated it
scares me how much of it reminds me of
my 8r capsule after this after
dissecting the vivarium machine that
read activated it's clear that why who
copied my capsule project and
constructed the scene to hold read the
read simulation it's actually very
similar in its construction except for
one point where my capsule houses flat
people constructed from the model neuro
graphs but the vivere ins brain scan
lives on it isn't limited by its content
from the originating brain scan read and
merge the read inside the vivarium was a
perfect copy I have it I can save
humanity I can build an artificial
reality capsule they can hold every
living member of pathos - I can't figure
out how it worked with the vivarium but
I can replicate without scanning
technique using the pilot seats they are
already prepared with the type of
electromagnetic drums needed even easier
than I thought I guess that explains the
mockingbirds stolen scans pilot seed
basis for intelligence surprisingly
positive reaction scan all people we can
find and load them in the castle then we
launch it in space using the space gun
see mark Saran killed himself after his
scan he's been suggesting everyone
should kill themselves as it would
somehow allow them to actually get on
the ark
not sure how that would work it did
trigger a lot of arguments alone staff
and apparently it's my fault somehow
Strom Iyer was not happy with me hope it
will come down okay Richard gimme it
Richard gave me instead of a templates I
haven't seen before unfold one of them
to make a new friend Catherine capsule
Catherine and her gang a legacies new
way to simulate turbulence makes a
weather system so much better implement
did Reid didn't go well new try with
Reid we won't play nicely with others
she is too real so Reid is the scan from
the varium but the vivere him up from
the Wow
apparently this idea wasn't hers
originally like they talked about the
wau as being rogue artificial
intelligence and more like a cancerous
gross than anything smart but there was
some reason why it was copying people in
the first place like why was that that
is a weird thing excuse me chair pardon
me a lot of questions here not a lot of
answers what's a little projective
what's Oh mate that's my attempted
building of a variant it's kind of a
proto art uh-huh so what did you find
the vivarium or something whoa what is
that you have a lot of toys huh hmm well
you don't have anything more to say
about that exercise is for the weak and
the people with not robot body junk
looks like something you'd fish out of
the ocean huh oh you mean
yeah the supportive reads with varium
it's it's a long story
forget it Lulu look what I got Miss
Catherine okay what not gonna talk about
this this is weird
I'm grabbing your underwear not weird at
all not weird is this weird why aren't
you talking about this
why aren't you mentioning this I'm being
weird talk about how weird I am no all
right then fine
welcome to the whole episode where I
creepily look through all of Catherine's
stuff this is guy that killed himself
it's not good dear friends when you read
this I will have entered the ark as I've
explained this is accomplished by wait
oh here you'll see by ceasing to live as
your scan is being completed do not
frighten Catherine I will do this in
secret by folding cyanide salts and
chewing gum and placing it in my mouth
before seeing her when I hear her
announce completion I will bite down
causing quickly causing my own demise
when you discover the truth behind my
death no there's no tragedy to mourn for
I'm victorious I advise you all to do
the same and join me inside the Ark
that's probably not how it works
at all god that's that I don't know
understand the reasoning behind that but
that is one of the great thought
questions it comes in all this
we died Sunday few days while others
live a few years
we're not affected by their short
lifespans as they are replaced by new
cells which help sustain our bodies and
I don't think any moment of um we ever
lose our persona due to this process
yet we are clay in a constant state of
transformation then how do we remain the
same a continuous flow of thought and
perception keeps an unbroken chain of
continuity that we know as our self our
conscious mind is not the pattern of our
brain for the continuous emergent entity
based on that pattern when dr. John
populates the arc during a moment of our
existence and placing it inside the
digital world so you and your did you
know you will grow past due to diverging
experiences but for a tiny window you
are the very same we unbroken continuity
will evolve a fulfilling life no doubt
no less season than the one from which
it was you only you
you are the emergent entity that just
happens to occupy two places at once for
a while
if you took away your body you would
simply be the only one you can be the
you inside the arc
let your body die and continue on in the
digital paradise among the stars see
that's that that's the reasoning behind
it that's what a lot of people say
especially when the Sun when this comes
up and there's actually I've been
reading up a lot of discussion about
this too and that does come up a lot
because they say as it's obvious that
there's a lot of there's a lot of
philosophers out there internet armchair
philosophy oh gosh it doesn't look good
armchair philosophy yeah I get it
not good oh hello this looks fun so it's
like it's a big it's a big thought thing
like you are yourselves replace
themselves entirely entirely every atom
every single atom in your body changes
out like what is it every seven years
every every ten years I forget what the
exact time frame loves it but every
single cell in your body is replaced
everything and not just cell every
single atom in your body is replaced
cycled out made from new yada yada yada
so it's really interesting to to think
about all that as a con to a
continuation of who you are like are you
a different person because seven years
ago you were physically literally a
different person made up of different
molecules that may follow different
individual rules and nuances and stuff
it's a confusing thing and like Who am I
to say my answer is right compared to
that answer but it's just like in my
understanding of it then dard we're all
dying anyway I'm all in I put my face in
Sarang in the continuity yeah yeah cuz
that's the thing like it like everyone
everyone knows one constant in all this
philosophical debate about what what you
have and what what could be and what not
could be you think that you know
you are you but everyone can accept the
idea that the you that you are will
eventually end there's a set beginning
in a set end to most people's lives
depending on wow that guy did not look
friendly I only caught the tiniest
little glimpse of him but he's not gonna
be a fun time it's so weird that this
game conjures up so many interesting
thoughts like I know it's probably like
especially if you don't unders stop
before it's our release obviously very
confusing and I can't on-the-fly while
I'm playing summarise me
I can't summarize all my thoughts
perfectly but what I can do is I can try
to piece together the narrative of what
this game is all about and why why
people reach the reasoning that they do
especially in these circumstances which
is quite interesting because there's
varied opinions on the subject and
there's various reasons for why one
person would lead down one path and one
person would lead down another like in
their mind they would they would
technically it when killing themselves
after they've copied their mind in their
minds they think that when they do that
they are simply leaving their body and
then waking up in the you know India
in the arc that's a thought hey where
did my scam and all the others I suppose
you don't remember my skin was the first
had to test the scanner before I could
start making promises okay cool so the
wau was actually created but then it
went rogue apparently troubleshoot hello
error codes Leonard the reset router in
the sublevel vault or contact
maintenance okay so I can't use this
thing until I reset the router stress
key come in I need help in the lab the
scan room what happened
Conrad killed himself after the scan
Jesus how come nazar tool what should I
do I'm gonna need to tell Stromer no
please so close strong wires gonna shut
down the arc project it's not my fault
people keep killing themselves Catherine
what are you gonna do it's not like you
can sneak a 300-pound body out of the
lab I know Catherine are you okay
not even close sounded like she was in
shock after what happened I mean I can't
imagine like constantly every time this
happens you know you have a sneaking
suspicion someone's gonna kill
themselves as soon as they're done with
the scan that's that's gotta be insane
what check the terminal I just want to
make sure what do you want to make sure
of what is it compressing the cut
Jeannie neuro graph ok Nanami erase data
I don't want to erase data
why would I erase the data I shouldn't I
probably shouldn't just be pushing
buttons oh Munchie Munchie Munchie
Munchie Munchie
it's not good Munchie how did this what
is this subject wait
Jared Jared that was my name my name is
you're Simon Jared there what do you
have a file of me you are one of dr. mum
she's templates the legacy scan uh hey
this guy was almost burnt born when I
was I was born June 28 1989 hey cool all
right post scan all right let's start
again okay that's it
wow that was fun that's it really still
figuring this out so it's freaky so many
lights what do we do now Paul and I are
gonna run test for a weaker show then
we'll work out a road map to your
recovery well I feel excited can't wait
to get back to living this isn't gonna
end well
I have a feeling we've worked everything
out everything is legal notes for by dr.
Peake and professor way oh that's great
news no big change of medication you'll
be taking an aspirin every morning but
that's about it all worked out a diet
with some variations you should try out
you can continue doing physical therapy
also there's some extra cardio training
every other day okay
getting complicated don't worry it's
really not we're gonna keep an eye on
you every week so we'll be able to
adjust the plan if needed that is it
that doesn't really seem like a whole
lot of things that you're changing to
make things better the model was sound
it should have worked
it's not your fault I really would
things had turned out differently yeah
me too I'm supposed to save you hey you
got my brain on file maybe you can put
it to some use yeah who knows you'd be
okay with that
using it for my research sure it's like
a part of me lives on or something like
a donated org you know what sucks about
dying what the crash everything up till
now brain damage you guys everything
it's made my life so much more real I
started thinking about all the things I
was going to do I've never been more
excited to be alive all that hope ways
to do
oh listen witness their historic
templates Brad construction any
self-respecting engineer would use
legacies anymore but they're grateful
learning they come with every
development kit so my brain scan turned
into a template for artificial
intelligence you should be proud so much
for that mystery no magic or time-travel
neat I was here all along waiting for
someone to shove a picture of my brain
into his suit and hit the power button
how weird is that how weird is the
thought of that that if you just like
take a scan of your brain you would
literally like like not you in this body
but you as like the entity inside a
memory you would just go on living as if
you'd never die like this when I started
the art contract so pretty much left in
this lab see that's so bizarre so
bizarre okay I'd still need to reset the
thing in the basement it's no need to do
the thing in the basement think of the
basement thing in the basement thing in
the basement anything here that I need
anything here that I can explore I
apologize
are they similar to my legacy file no
you're just flattered if that makes
sense less dynamic Thanks that makes me
feel much better
hmm weird why is it sparking should this
be sparking probably not boo boo boo boo
I probably shouldn't start playing with
things okay so I'm not gonna mess with
anything here until I know exactly what
I'm messing with because frankly it
would be irresponsible for me to start
doing that it's like it would be
irresponsible for me to start erasing
data willy-nilly okay anyway I was gonna
say I apologize if this episode is a
little low on action and slow pace just
because there's a lot to explore and
there is a lot to understand and there's
a lot to comprehend because there's a
lot of things going on here but how
weird is that idea the entire concept
that you all that you are could be
copied and then moved and then just
restart somewhere else and it would go
on and then it would follow a different
path and become a completely different
person than what you would be that is so
weird
okay the last report filed by the staff
mentioned struggling with something
called proxy the proxy we killed was
blind just like Akers but it listens
careful we spotted two more by the
infirmary what do they look like now
sure it seems to be human enough to pass
for a crew member at a distance tall
dark and ultimately faceless seems to be
what to look out for keep my eyes open
that doesn't sound good at all so it's
the way I you creating monsters here oh
this is gonna be fun well this is gobble
out a humdrum fun going on down here
oh goody goody gumdrops okay is this
gonna break on me oh I can't wait for
that oh okay I think I'm fine oh well
alrighty then
eeny meeny miny moe no way in hell am i
going through that one oh good it's dead
end
Oh sure picked a winner over here well
did my exploring for the day
okay so anyway thank you everybody so
much for watching I ran out of time for
this episode here but I just wanted to
say that even though this episode was
very story filled you know like for some
reason like I enjoyed myself here more
than I have in the past few episodes
just because there's so much there's so
much meat the story to chew into there's
so much things to think about I need
like a whole day to process all this
just so I can keep moving forward in the
game but the next part is probably gonna
be really scary so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video